in honor of
the
memory of drew brees setting that
all-time record our draft for today
peter king
is
records that are within
reach and i actually
i put on my thinking cap i did some
research i tried to be a little creative
and hopefully i identified enough that
are plausible that are within reach so
you will get the first pick if you get
this trivia question right drew brees
holds the record for most consecutive
regular season games with a touchdown
pass who holds the record peter for the
most consecutive playoff games with a
touchdown pass
joe montana
oh no brett favre your good friend brett
favre 20 straight playoff games wow with
a touchdown pass tom brady is second
with 18.
and brees is third with 16 and that
streak for him still actives brady's is
not all right uh first pick for me and
man
the ones i came up with are so obscure
there really isn't one that just jumps
off the page at me you're right
i i'm gonna go though with the all-time
passing yards record because right now
drew brees has it at 77 416. brady has
74
571 and so by next year if brees isn't
playing and taysom hill is the
quarterback of the saints and brady
plays a second season with the
buccaneers that's brady's shot to
eclipse drew brees and retire as the
all-time passing yardage leader
you know i like that one mike i i think
though what is he how much is he ahead
of him now like three thousand
something just under three thousand uh
2900
yeah yeah yeah i was going to say that
you know when i was looking over a few
of these i thought of that but
i i mean
i think brees is going to throw for
i don't know whatever 4 700 yards
and and and and if he does
you know he's gonna he's gonna lengthen
that lead this year so if brady plays
next year and look
bruce arians believes mike that tom
brady is not playing two more years he's
playing three
and so
you know so i think you're probably
right
i just wonder if he only plays two more
and breeze puts the record out so big
and so so
if he gets such a big lead after this
year
will brady be able to catch him next
year we'll see okay
the one i'm gonna take is a little bit
obscure
and that is the all-time passer rating
record as of now
uh russell wilson trails aaron rodgers
by 1.2 points
rogers is 102.4 wilson's 101.2
the reason why i think rogers is
vulnerable in this area is that not only
is russell wilson going to play another
10 years at a very efficient low
interception level
also aaron rodgers four of his last five
seasons his ratings been under 98
so he is trending a little bit in this
direction and russell wilson
is basically flatlining and so i think
wilson's going to end up 102 103 for his
career
and that'll be ahead of aaron rodgers on
that list
yeah i like that one and uh with the
passer ratings generally trending higher
and higher and higher that would seem to
give russell wilson a better chance as
well just because all of the great
quarterbacks are more efficient and
generating those better numbers than
they used to be all right next one for
me and but i really i'm gonna i'm gonna
rattle off all the obscure ones i found
at some point this one isn't all that
obscure though the all-time receptions
record jerry rice has 1549
and lo and behold larry fitzgerald has
1378 he's 171 behind rice that is if he
plays two more years 85 one year 86 the
next to get there he had 75 last year in
kyler murray's first season with deandre
hopkins there drawing double coverage
this year fitz may get even more than
what he saw last year he's no longer the
guy that anyone is going to be giving
extra attention to
the question is how much more gas does
he have in the tank it's felt like he's
gonna retire the last five years but he
just keeps going and going and going and
you wake up one day and you look at his
numbers and you say holy crap he
actually has a chance to break a record
that we thought would never be broken
yeah you know what mike i have asked
jerry
asked jerry ice i've asked larry
fitzgerald about that a lot over the
years i asked him last year and he said
the same thing he said look
that re that record belongs to the goat
there's no chance i'm going to touch
that record well
at the end of this year if it's a normal
nfl season if it's not coronavirus
shortened
larry fitzgerald is going to be
75 catches away
from jerry rice now look and everybody
says well how can you say that he's
going to have whatever 75 or 80 catches
this year deandre hopkins is on the team
blah blah blah all this other stuff look
larry fitzgerald doesn't get hurt
kyler murray loves him
larry fitzgerald is the leader of the
team he runs perfect routes perfect
and to me
no matter how great deandre hopkins is
for that team no matter how great kirk
and the and the young receivers are on
that team larry fitzgerald is going to
get his catches now i'm going to give
you one that pro i'm not even sure i
believe in okay
but i'm going to give you one that that
that is a little bit
i'm reaching okay because i think one of
the things we're seeing in football
today is we're not going to see
some of the length of careers to get
these incredible records
but
i think there is a legitimate chance
in in you know if he plays six or seven
years
and he plays at the level that he has
that julio jones can catch jerry rice on
the all-time uh you know yardage list
now again he'd have to probably play
seven productive years can he do that
will he want to do that
uh he certainly will be with a
quarterback who's going to allow him to
do that in matt ryan because they're
going to fill the air with footballs but
right now he's about 10 000 yards 10 600
yards behind jerry rice i'm not saying
it's probable
but i'm saying when i look at modern
players
okay who have the ability to do great
things by extending their careers
sign me up for julio jones
and you know on that point i agree with
you i looked at that record and i also
looked at the all-time receiving
touchdowns record that's one that is not
going to be touched anytime soon there's
no one active who has a snowball's
chance in hell of catching jerry rice's
190 or somewhere between 190 and 200
whatever it is no one is on track no
one's on pace no one's even remotely
close that's not happening one more from
me the all-time sax record not sax made
sax absorbed peter the all-time record
for sax taken currently is held
by it's a record
bread
has 525 for his career ben
roethlisberger is second all-time with
503.
he's only 22 behind ben
if you're really focused if you really
apply yourself you can do it i believe
in you ben that you can get the 520. i
believe in you ben
hey look my last one it's not going to
be for any leader of the pack thing
but i believe that uh that terrell suggs
is going to break into the top five of
the all-time sack list he needs right
now 11 to be able to do or 12 rather to
be able to do that
and i think he's got the kind of body
where he's going to play one or two more
years
not that he's playing for a number but i
do think he's got the kind of body that
is in such good shape when he went to
the chiefs last year at the end of the
year andy reid and others just marveled
at him how he was an elastic man how he
looked like he was 22 years old so i say
suggs breaks into the top five but i'm
sorry terrell suggs
you are
uh 61 away from bruce smith you won't be
catching bruce smith until you play
about five more years in tom brady
yeah and you know what von miller told
you last year that he wants to catch
bruce smith but he had a very non-von
miller year last season he's still got
94 to go to ty bruce smith and von
miller's on the wrong side of 30. all
right quick break but before we get
there a couple of others that i i
they caught my eye and they were worthy
of mention records that are within reach
all-time game-winning drives peyton
manning has 54. drew brees currently has
50. all-time pick six is brett favre of
what a shock has 31. drew brees has 27.
phillip rivers has 24. matthew stafford
has 20. that record's within reach
all-time extra points made if adam
vinatieri keeps going he's got 8.74 he
could maybe eventually catch george
blanda with 9.43 and last but not least
the all-time two-point conversions
record marshall falk has seven
and drum roll please big trusts mark
ingram has five he can catch marshall
fall
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports